yeah welcome to this video David was on
final and I'm trying again to win this
bloody tournament it didn't make it I
didn't manage the last couple of times
and I'm making a real effort now to do
it trying to play especially quickly and
trying to play in a bit more aggressive
style to win croquet it's probably going
to cost the odd game here down but I'm
trying okay so this is a poner with the
Queen exchange unfortunately okay by
winning winning the Sun right okay that
was quickly
okay that's right I'll play gambits lab
oops we are possible and and debits that
are halfway serious at least not some
some stuff where you just a pawn down
for nothing probably try that 95 come on
give me 90 5-4 win of the Queen yes yeah
this is the good thing got something
with those gambits from the other guy
does something something bad you
sometimes wind really quickly okay new
game come on I'm not so sure about my
gambit line against e4 might be yeah the
Goering gambit yeah just a just a pawn
now black with no compensation she tried
to Castle long maybe
ya don't see a way to two colors that
yeah trying to to play quickly Wow why
why are you added two major it's late
what does he move the king maybe it's
some sort of pre move don't know ok I
wanted to go if all ok but he resigned
so an early lead of 11 points which
doesn't really mean much maybe I can go
for the bank oh yeah until he's playing
a very solid set up against the bank oh
I'll try to go for a file but he's some
preventing it at the moon maybe I can
yeah I can get the five square I can go
here and the end OG 5 cementing us night
here yeah probably here I need to get
rid of on one look at least the endgame
was only slightly better for me now it's
a winning no I definitely won't draw ok
so 20 points ahead love this bloody
window now maybe go for this bank or
style stuff maybe he's not seeing that
ever taking the bishop sometimes need to
play those kind of stuff got an active
position trying to address him maybe
here and d5 if he goes to f5 it's a very
active position and I've got ya good tea
for coming threatening to take it's a
bit uncomfortable here oh I've got no
I've got this getting the King out of
out in the open not it's not it's not
exactly clear oh this is this noise is
getting getting ugly d 3 mmm just got a
check here yeah anyway
should be good threatening rookie to
rupee for all kinds of all kinds of
nasty things so what now is he
threatening something maybe just TM and
now the Queen trade but I've got the
depot and it's still a very active very
active production probably needs to go
no I think he needed to go Rupe do you
want get rid of the porn we've been thus
now on we'll get very tricky for him
threatening hey for now a4a three yeah I
three they cannot take you because of
Roxy form okay I said you cannot take
oops so this is nick stroke yeah spawn
promotes and this guy is not resigning
unfortunately
I know it's letting the clock run down I
don't believe it your rec yeah whatever
yeah some sound effects doesn't help it
doesn't resign okay so come on give me a
new game I'm Julian good good rhythm
going here oops okay yeah I don't even
need to sacrifice myself it's just just
killing himself probably ok let's open
up the position no maybe I shouldn't
have a note this possible Queen trade
but it's not it's not bad for me at all
yeah he can no Castle long unfortunately
hello it's probably a no advantage which
is a really bad result against the
Latvian gambit which is really just bad
well but I didn't really take good use
of that you need to exchange this light
squared Bishop its Sun it's a nuisance
this piece now try to do something
against them at the h5 pole okay this is
some this is the only thing i have here
slide slightly better protected King
side so the pawn now is some the problem
if he goes Bishop h6 threatening its
threatening I am I can go mighty form
neither Sun nice on e4 anyway yeah this
is probably the easiest take stakes and
the palace it's very weak basically lost
I think yeah just take it
now don't really want to give up any
material let's use the edge pool yeah I
know the h-bond is so my winner
hopefully I hope I'm not walking into
some silly meeting net but I don't think
so maybe play that avoid any any mates
should do III sell for
yeah let's uh let's keep it simple here
okay Wow yeah my absolutely sub-optimal
clay really took a while here to win
this game okay but I'm I'm nicely ahead
here yeah again this guy from Iraq who
let the clock run down in the last game
yeah here it is the bishop sometimes you
just need to play on cheap cheap stuff
you could have just need to just retreat
it
no let's occupy the center quickly yup
short castle and then should I take it I
come on let's just develop
no can take it I'm on g3 now attending
to sacrifice Wow I'll take it everything
you offer me I'll take it yeah and now
is ok not letting the clock run down I
really expected that ok try to get to to
the king quickly Queen edge to now
threatening yeah you can take on you
three rookie three I go Queen f4 this is
strong and of course that's see one
hanging so I'm taking all this stuff now
96 oh this isn't this mate somehow
should be I hear there's the mate ok
43 points ahead I need to win this at
least once please okay in the fridge I
don't really think there's a good gambit
against the French so just a normal
aggressive set up 05 maybe I should have
taken okay but suppose I as a pre move
yeah it's still a very solid and normal
position for the French I don't mind to
exchange this bishop I'm getting rid of
my home doesn't okay maybe I can really
go let's let's play for a quick attack
yeah okay where to go maybe this first
and then Queenie to end long castles
yeah
yeah still the dark squared bishop is a
valuable piece for black I think he
argues that the queen is blocking the
h-bomb this is true but the queen is not
exactly a great unblock ating piece at
some point that will get tricky for him
for example all knowing he just moves it
away I had ideas like night f1 h 2 F 3
something like that with some
preparation beforehand and now I also
want to go to g5 truth f 32 g 4 have the
sacred square if it takes it's really
trying to go in a big-time evacuation
mode I'm trying for Bishop before here
activating the bishop this is what I
meant when I said that exchanging the
dark squared Bishop siz a problem it
leaves the dark squares very weakened
yeah this was the idea looks looks like
a very nice position might be five
coming
yeah getting out of this check here for
mode or d3 it doesn't have a good move
anyway yeah now I can can enter 96
coming now is actually defending this
yeah up to this point rather stubborn
game that that's a very very bad
position okay okay 50 points yeah maybe
here I cannot go for the Schliemann or
something yep so always fun to play and
really a good opening it's one of the
best gambit style openings that is
available really it's not always a
gambit but time and some it certainly
fits the gun gambit es mindset and it's
really good I mean it's really good
opening you need to learn a bit of
theory though it's not not easy okay
ideas now Oh to go here
no is in some some really uncomfortable
pin and this Bishop is also hanging I
can take him and now try to get pressure
on the on the edge phone hmm can I go
don't know okay let's play catan many
good good ideas maybe night eight maybe
even night h5 was the possibility I
didn't want to place a complicated now
it's it should be good for me in any
case you don't need to play the most
complicated stuff I hope yeah let's keep
this closed and 95 is really really
strong out and you can take here or is
there something better even Knight f3
maybe neither thriller and take h2y not
intending my queen edge form and the
fear what I know this is a I cannot
survive this it's too much I needed to
take on h2 which is certainly am
dangerous for white but probably not not
immediately winning for black and this
is winning now don't think he's got
anything against bishop g3 or mmm so
first bishop g3 or i can just take a
disease
just look at 4g for looks strong enough
fo g four years the best way to go yeah
maybe I should something better let's
just get to d6 and win this okay keep it
simple don't want to allow loopy aid
okay yeah took took a bit longer than
necessary probably okay now the other
guy also that nine out of line it's not
bad push Nick off the walls I'm okay no
this was nice I was like anything
quickly design no
so not exactly a given it no but it's on
your right for black this age for stuff
I cannot really believe that this is too
too great this leads to some weekend
porn structure
I just want to keep the position close
now yeah okay the Queen traders of
course nice for me if he allows it he
didn't not so sure what the point is
therefore but I need to play a five
anyway opening up okay
yeah I have got behind Bishop g4 I mean
it's k it's not it's not terrible but I
could have could have had a bad night I
had had easier ways to go about that I
did it's it's a it's still excellent but
there were easier ways to to play yeah
at the end let's decide it on the Kings
side funny enough they cannot be fancy
three now
no no move what's the easiest okay I'm
up a copy for more not pawns and then
decide there's the quicker win it's a
bit strange actually maybe here
intending would be too if it takes on f8
look at the f file should be excellent
as well o gauge three coming okay I
could have taken the rook okay about the
sky is keeping keeping the pace playing
the deloitte Smith [ __ ] that's really
not much of a point in this Hut ok
trying to go directly for t6
maybe this was the wrong way to to play
ok ok now it's it's fine again it's two
pawns ok but I was a bit worried about
some some other others of other tries
this is certainly oh sure 35 yeah this
strong rupee 827 obvi should therefore
be sure the force may be stronger
stronger even he cannot play a 5 and d6
I've got Bishop c6 yeah this is Sam so
completely explodes now yeah this is
stronger than taking look at this poor
bishop
I don't need to take immediately quindi
eight now and what am I playing on Queen
d8 looks like that made in some moves or
something okay i can i can just play
Quincy five actually I kept a nice got
97 taking and Queen a seven I don't know
who I don't see a direct wooden and
maybe there isn't one it's possible
ah taking a group c seven maybe this is
good Queen datsheffy 7 Bishop e7 Roxy
seven bishops in six loops e6 dc-6
Brooke takes esox a twins okay what is
probably hurting the clock run down i am
i'm disconnected or what don't hope it's
just letting the clock run down yeah I
don't get it really why not just resign
play new game and have fun probably with
a new game I wanted to play game that's
right okay
job you can play you five this Frome's
from skin but I think oops come on I try
now to quickly attack the king
threatening to take T 2 and B 3 and 95
maybe also a bishop a 6 ok not 95 wow
you five maybe yeah I'm throttling
before now now I think he needs to take
what this looks are disastrous really
twill be three okay 14 out of 14 so now
this looks like a good scoring concept
just win the mall oops I want to go d
flow of course this is bad left what am
I doing here wanted to play d4 of course
hmm yeah
this is by far not junk I want to do it
but ok it's still it's still an okay
position now maybe it's good even if you
should have 36 and c7 so let's just
quickly get on the default King you
three check check baby oh this is made
yeah a bit lucky that he didn't hear I
didn't have any any good idea to make
use of my my mouth lips and stuff okay
transposed to the power come on it's at
least an open position
yeah it's a the typical isolated Queen
porn position it's very much like a
tirage defense and reserved in Reverse
not in reserve reversed yeah didn't do
much on a five so it's whoops it's just
centralized maybe you can take and play
look see 50 take
yeah I don't not show product not sure
this is great really but do I have a
good blockade yeah I'm hoping now that
the the night will prove to be a good
good mind a piece
ya can take be five at the end really
not what I want okay let's do this first
and hope that this is okay for me
came getting this porn now it's not
clear that it's really great for me
because my stuff is also week here no is
defending this really well surprisingly
well hoping for neither for ya at least
he's overlooking something
and now I'm letting the clock run down
as usual okay okay about 50 points ahead
this guy's got 14 out of 14 okay I come
on give me a new game no harm us again
germany okay yeah I cannot actually we
cannot play tomorrow on our case playing
the the dragon and I don't know the
google Slava check playing out oh this
is nice i like that that's a good
positional way to play with why just
being better
mmm how to get to the six pawn that's
the first make sure that the queen is a
position down mmm why did I allow the
five maybe he's preparing g5 okay for
night f5 okay this didn't materialise
trying to get the 93 why can't I can
take it but I hope my compensation is
fine with night f5 coming
92 92 92 out of the glue something like
that
trying to control f5 now you've got a
real problem with the Queen okay it's
got this this bloody square unbelievable
ok cannot take now I'm threatening queen
age three hopefully Queen h3 cookie
eight maybe Oh Jake
mighty fine and Queen f3
oops now okay I could really do any
commentary at the end what a weird game
with no time on the clock it's just a
matter of matter of nerves okay the
probably won't announce it correct
correctly run it tang and rang a tank or
something a German it's just all wrong
you don so it's a bit easier to
pronounce it's still the same somewhat
strange opening with before okay um but
it's still not like winning or something
just a convenient position for black but
not not not more a for maybe a 493 i
plate the setup here to make sure that
this bishops got an award no scope okay
let's prevent this he can go age for but
this is really am really a bit much okay
Bishop g4 or rookie to rookie to
actually assume i rather serious threat
now now look into cannot play this but i
can i can take him
this is just just nice now threatening
rookie to d3 all kinds of stuff well
it's got very bad um piece placement
okay maybe prepare this d3 yeah it's at
least an exchange actually less than I
hope for considering how overwhelming
this position was
yeah but ok it's a it's a pretty pretty
easy window yeah I'll take it ok I'm
really optimistic now 89 of 18 this
guy's got 1,600 six times I've a little
let's play the heavens but it's a good
risky this guy is a pretty decent player
d6y DISA don't know d 6 in this position
it has been played against me before and
I always wasn't sure if this is really a
move but isn't this good for why I mean
he's got rid of bad King now the nollans
is 95 actually instead of d 6 this is
what I play myself I want to open it up
playing through directly maybe this is
too straightforward even also go mmm
yeah but take it can take what the Queen
don't know maybe this one intending to
take with the pawn yep now I hope to
learn to get it back
hmm and ce4 and they'd be good now rook
t1 or t3 this would be a really nice
position he still has got this issue
with the king
I'm all known I'm on e5 pretty pretty
often so Wow na kuhne f5 g6 this is Sir
this must be must be great now cannot
believe like is going to survive survive
that so just here Jo yet just just rupee
eight okay the heavens did it did its
job I cannot believe that with 19 of 19
I'm still not know I don't want to
resign us again this guy apply flayed
him plating before okay I'm trying to
get something quickly here based on the
on this pin
oh this is this is tricky nigeria end
and now know is exploding on c3 I hope
so Queen B 5 don't know is this a win
direct when I mean again it's not to
stop just take it this only one point to
win in this game on I mean war zone was
on terms may be more than one point but
now used to to look for more than I just
got some exchange and it's still a good
attack
there should be five thises this is
stupid ok kool kombi should be five
before this would have been really
really annoying yeah this should win the
Queen maybe Luke c2 was even quicker
well this was probably quicker and now
we will again spend 40 seconds staring
at this crap position you know not this
time okay yeah for once okay yeah trying
to go how this hack attack I think it's
called that way I got a hack attack in
this case it's a it's just strong I
think this this is Tom hack attack
somehow means that it's a it's a bit
unsound or something this is just just
very dangerous at least I hope night
well maybe here fighting for h6
fluttering rookie one yep cutting the
king and threatening nigeria 95 and you
don't have a square needs to give the
Queen down okay so 21 in a row that's
other guy yeah okay this guy he's always
playing for this for this stuff and I
I'll try something now I just won't
Castle short i'm curious what is going
to do then okay just sacrificing stuff
No
all right i'll take some material
attacking the rook and attending kareena
320 of three baby and 93 this when's
your queen
okay 80 points this should be enough
come on okay actually lost some game one
hundred percent is a rare result I
manage this before but just once or
twice okay 23 I remember that I once got
above 400 points but this was funny we
had two quick resign your sale there
again 24 now okay this really it seems
like I'm able to to to stop this to stop
this batch of second places okay it's a
slow way to to play yep I don't really
like the spin
with the night if he takes and then you
cannot actually not have any to go here
this is not so bad actually I have
chances to get ya not even chances I'm
getting this this knight on d5 the
question is how exactly should I play
maybe take care really nice this knight
on d5 yeah I think you should take like
40 really ok
hmm i'm not sure if all this was so
great you can grow it for you know f4 i
really had some doubts if you want go
ahead for this now is a nice control
again can go rook d3 for example to well
strengthen h5 also have let's play h5
make sure oh yeah okay of course Queens
off
don't my dad don't want Bishop e2 of
course now the king must go to d3
the King needs to learn to help like to
exchange rooks of course yeah this one
pop rocks yeah this is a winning end
game I windy a pond with the brilliant
night iam yeah just stop everything it's
the easiest mmm wait maybe it's even
easier if I oh I think the time not okay
I didn't manage to win the last game but
it's one of those tournaments where you
really know you you didn't do much wrong
just 20 24 out of 24 and win again after
some some yeah less convincing results I
played a bit more aggressively and a bit
more quicker maybe bit okay I hope you
enjoyed it a couple of wins in a row and
I'll be back soon